Hôm nay, người hai vì bà thân từ công mang tấn đất lắt tổ chức họ báo của bố Thông tin
vụ tên nặng cho thông kiến họp xin lớp 12 tữ vòng.
Tại nữ họp báo đã tả của ở vía tốn, phó trứng đốc công an tấn đất lắt cho biết
qua quá tình điều tra, cơ quan tình cho điều tra đã khởi tối của an, khởi tối bị càng
rưu của ý cử thiếu ta, nhuyễn quan quan,
tính bộ thuộc đầm cành cho được thông của đồng vực.
Theo thông tin chính thức của công an tình tại buổi họp báo của mùi một dựa
hệ miếp phút này, mười lâm thẳn đưa năm hành hành khúc chạm hay sấu,
ông ủyn quanh hoang là tấn mộ tổ tình tra của trạm thẳn thẳn thẳn thẳn thông
của đồng vực, năng tình tra trên trứng đường Quốc lộ hệ miếc chiến thộ
biểu phẩm giá phân đường răng và sát chư pân tình đất lắt.
Thực điểm này ông hẳn phát hiện, anh về địa quy,
sinh năm hành hành khúc chạm để tắng, chú tại buôn chư băng, sát chư pân,
điều khiển xe gắn mấy, biển kìm sát, bốn mấy bài ác bê, ba hai năm,
bày tắng, đi ngăn qua, nhi ngờ anh quy có giấu hiểu vi phạm hành chính,
tuy nhiên thay vì thực hiện đúng quy chình ra hiệu lại vương tựa đề kìm tra
ông hòa ngã điều khiển xe mù tổ đặc trung lội theo phía sau.
Thì đến kì lộ mết một trong chiếm mi tắng cộng hai chẳn Quốc lộ hai mi chính,
anh quy không làm chủ được tay lấy, lăng vào mừng thích nước bên trái,
thông ướng tự Quốc lộng quy bốn, đi sả e-gép, tuy nhiên sau khi sẽ thay nạn,
dù là cán bộ cảnh sát dầu thông đặc là nghiệm vụ, ông thàng không dừng lại kìm tra,
hỗ trợ nạn nhân mà quay sây dời khỏi hiện trường.
Hậu qua, anh quy từ vong trong quá trình, được chuyển viện các cứu từ bệnh viện đa qua hoa
mình, nỉnh bệnh đa qua bụt tinh winh.
Công ăn tình đặc lắc sát định hành vi của ông quyến khoảng hàng có giấu hiệu có thành tội,
không cứu giúp người đang ở trong tình trắng quy hiệm đi tính nạn.
Quý định tại giềm A, B, khoảng 2, điều 1 trong bói 2 bụt lợi thình sự.
Ngày 28 tấn từ năm 2020, các quan tảng sát điều tra của anh tình đã ra quyết định khởi tố vụ án,
nông thời khởi tố bị càn bối bệnh ông quyến khoảng hàng để điều tra theo quy định phúc lợi.
Tại bội học báo, nhiều phóng viên nạn đặt cố hỏi liên quan đến chắc nhận quan li cắn bộ,
quy trình tình tình trà kiểm sát só thông, cũng như việc gần trình hoạt động của lực lượng chức năng.
Nằm chắn sản xa những vụ việc bất dự, đại giản của anh tình cho biết sẽ thân cường kiểm tra sức trọng
khi lợi kỳ cương trong ti hàng công vụ. Lối với ý kiến đề cập đến tự trạng học sinh điều kiện xe máy,
xe đặc điện khi chưa đủ điều kiện, tìm anh Wicker mất an toàn sáo thông.
Lực lượng chức năng đến mạnh, cân nỉ mạnh phối hợp giữa ngành tung an, sáo dục và ra định trong việc quản lý,
quyến chuyển năng cao ý thức trách hành phóc lợi cho học sinh. Đừng thời gia sát có biển pháp kiểm sát sát thay phu hợp.
Nhân bảo đằng an toàn khi thăm sà sáo thông.